thank you
thank you find that dress in a slightly
bigger size and own it because it's so
great isn't this cute well this is my
second time on the show the first time
on the show I went out and bought a
fancy dress for you yeah this is not me
this is no this was 42 on the internet
ever since weed became legal I dress
like a psychic in Santa Fe going through
a divorce
you're pulling it off it's kind of cute
right yeah the horses I love it hey you
go on the road quite a bit do you ever
visit any national parks you know what I
don't because I don't exercise yeah
because I hurt myself I rolled my ankle
at the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame and
everyone was like you're not allowed to
do anything active anymore we my health
insurance is just not good enough so do
you do you like being on the road I love
touring I love love touring but I'm
terrible at Logistics I'm bad at math
like we're artists and then we're
expecting to be good at math well I have
to sometimes post on social media where
I'm going and I mess up the dates like
I'm going to Miami right and I'm posting
like 22 cities and I'm like I can't wait
to come to Miami can't wait to come to
Miami everyone's like we can't find the
tickets I'm like I don't know what's
going on I find out I'm going to Miami
Oklahoma
there's a Miami Oklahoma first of all
it's pronounced Miami it's not Miami
it's Miami national parks guy you do you
know what national parks guy foreign
do you know what I mean it's called
Miami Oklahoma and I was like okay I'm
going to Miami right but in the email
they kept writing Miami okay okay oh
like okay and I'm like okay focus yeah
and then it's okay it's Oklahoma oh my
God yes so I I just I can't be trusted
to like do my own
Dad I'm gonna go to Miami Florida at
some point uh I love go do you perform
in Miami yeah it's the best they party
fun audience they party like it doesn't
matter how much you suck they're still
like drunken just having such a good
it's such a good time
you to be there yeah so Miami uh a lot
of times people want to come and film
shows now and with stand up it's a
little tricky because you're like I
don't want this to go on YouTube before
I shoot a special and there were these
girls that were filming during the show
and I didn't want them to post it and so
I'm going to take it down and so I was
like you know what girls can you maybe
stop filming we can take pictures
together at the end and they looked at
me going oh we're not we're not filming
you we're filming ourselves
attention that drives me nuts sometimes
and I don't care if people film wherever
but it's just like can we just be
present no like in the moment is it okay
for you to put it down nothing will
happen well I don't know in this day and
age politically something might happen I
don't know what'll happen but it's just
I don't know people are crazy but what
do people say to you like fans you
poopies you tour I I feel very lucky
because I do stand up I share a lot of
like sort of my personal stuff I I do
podcasts so a lot of people know a lot
about me so people feel very comfortable
coming up to me in public and like
sharing intimate details about
themselves because I've done it and and
people will just come up to me in
airports and they'll be like um I have
two kids and I like one better than the
other one and then they'll just walk off
and I like one better than the other one
you don't tell me that but I think I
think that because I share so much
intimate stuff about my life I think
people feel like they should share it
with me one woman was like sometimes I
hide in my car down the street so I
don't have to see my kids
[Applause]
I'm running errands and I just hide in
my car I'm like that's kind of like it
I'm like oh mommy's gonna go to the
bathroom like 40 minutes later
so I did not know it's the last time you
were here but I heard that you have done
an impression of me I can't believe I'm
even telling you this uh when I first I
want to hear it I don't want to tell you
this remember the show Mad TV yes when I
first moved to Los Angeles I auditioned
for Mad TV and I don't do characters I
don't do Impressions but I loved your
music video for since you've been gone
me too where you were just like freaking
out for three minutes I got to break
things all day and got paid for it
and so I was like I'm just gonna do an
impression of Kelly Clarkson and I went
in the audition room and I just like
started throwing stuff around and
smashing stuff and like screaming and
going nuts and I did not get the job uh
shocking I just like I just took a bunch
of Adderall and just went crazy
basically and looking back now you know
when you look back at things you did in
your early 20s and I like I can't
believe they didn't call the police yeah
are you any better at auditions now no
no no not graded out I just I start
getting sweaty like I get too anxious at
auditions you know you're so great
though thank you okay I agree but
I agree
when you go on the road do you take
anything because I do do you take
anything special on the road when I'm on
the road I am I'm not a game on the road
I pack I bring my own microphone on the
road your own microphone I bring a
microphone with me so I'm not sharing
like a microphone with 300 Road Comics
spitting weird nasty you know I've never
thought about that you've got to bring
your own I do that at like radio show
shows and all the artists get up there I
have to share Mike that's disgusting
yeah there's an old like there's like
old lipstick on it and just nasty chin
beard why did my people take care of me
and I don't have their might okay that's
gross but do you take anything else but
you do have to be careful in the airport
when a microphone goes through TSA a lot
of times they don't know it's a
microphone
so
you really have to stop and be like this
does not vibrate there's just not a
battery that is a microphone I swear
yeah you're like but if it did vibrate I
mean look if they make that product I'm
not gonna freak out yeah that's your
problem yeah it's called Shark Tank by
the way
so I hear you love Nashville you love
stopping I'm obsessed with Nashville I'm
going to be on Nashville on the tour
yeah I love going to Nashville uh
because of the Vintage short stores yes
they have the best vintage shopping uh
but I think I might stop doing it
because last time I went I got this like
awesome denim jacket it had all these
like patches on it and pins and I wore
it all the time on Instagram like I have
a horse and you know I ride my horse in
this jacket and I loved it so much and I
got this DM one day from this guy who
was like hey my ex got mad at me and
sold a bunch of my stuff to a vintage
store
I think you first of all that's awesome
I know how have I not thought of that
is amazing you're you're trashing your
stuff plus making profits
this woman is an entrepreneur and she
sounds awesome and uh seriously can I
have it back and I was like yeah I guess
so I sent it back did you tell him for
this amount of money I know I bought it
yeah sorry she's a turd but yeah so that
and then the other thing about going to
the South is I'm still trying to figure
out like what everything means and you
can probably help me with the southern
colloquialism yes what does bless your
heart mean
does it it means you're stupid well
right there's there's like it's it
depends on the tone and who you're
saying it to okay so when I go to the
South they'll ask me where I'm from and
I'm like I live in LA and they're like
yeah
[Applause]
or it's like you know it's well it's not
a compliment sometimes
and it's a southerner's way of of being
shady yes yeah but doesn't it sound nice
it's like British people cursing you out
it's rude but I like it yeah yeah and
then I learned the hard way that when a
woman sat in the South says she's fixing
to pitch a fit I'm fixing a pitch a fish
get out of there get out of there yeah
and grab anything that belongs to you
because she'll sell it too
a southern woman no she's smart and then
also it's it's tea sweet already
[Applause]
no what's you gotta if you want tea
that's sweet you just say I'd like some
tea well but what if you don't want
sweet tea no I my heart is
I'm you know what though I'm Different
like I don't really do sweet tea anymore
yeah I just fell in love with hot tea
okay all my Southern French just
disowned me but I'm poor thing
um
with my teeth
um so you have thoughts on Valentine's
Day I hear well yes Valentine's Day is
coming up very soon yes and I feel like
every year guys screw it up
looking at you
not the park guy not the park guy so I
have some ideas for guys that are
watching the show that want some advice
so I'm gonna who where am I looking who
am I going oh I'm gonna look into here
the guy up there I'm looking at you sir
if you're buying a
[Applause]
lot no I've warned you no one warned you
all of a sudden my band did just really
want to be apart you know so just start
playing
oh God okay we were playing music under
your PSA oh geez okay all right I'm
sweating look I'm sweating now look
advice for the guys you ready go t in
the back you ready
all right if you're buying ladies a gift
for Valentine's Day get a gift card I
know it's impersonal get a gift card I
promise you I promise you
I promise you it will be less of a fight
than buying something in the wrong size
also if you are buying something for
your girlfriend of two or more years and
decide to buy her jewelry that's not an
engagement ring
I suggest you give her that jewelry box
wearing a helmet
because you're about to get concussed
sir
that's amazing God speech okay thank you
thank you
thank you for that PSA the last part was
like two years wear a helmet did she
gonna beat you oh my god when dogs after
two years they're like here's a necklace
out of here out of here out of here you
take that joy and Shove It bless your
heart bless your heart I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this